foreign
Park
pay attention just for a second
[Applause]
work I think I'm ready for Duty do you
feel ready I think Stanley isn't getting
missing
what's the call
ing to reporter bank robbery is this
crime currently in progress today see
that guy on the bench do you have a
lighter that goes up to something
it's very hot today
it's like a furnace
it's
like a furnace
there's a safe deposit box is that the
target 23.
[Music]
heads up but I'm the wrong man
thank you
where is she
foreign
on the bank heist who the hell are you
what makes total strangers pull off an
elaborate bank heist are you familiar
with the concept of hypnotics hypnotics
hypnotics have the ability to influence
the brain sound
voice in a light blocking eyes
if not excused them to make you see a
version of the world that doesn't exist
thanks
saw him anymore next stop
I have to know everything
why me why my daughter
who's your dealing with
what you see isn't real
goodbye
products make everything that you see
and do
perfectly normal
foreign